في هذه الاثناء انتقد رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين التنياهو تصريحات رئيس
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
التي قل فيها ان تنفيذه هجوم اسرائيلي على
منشات نوويه في ايران غير قانوني وقال
نتنياهوسي شخص جدير لكنه ادلى بتصريحات
غير مناسبه واضاف ان اسرائيل ستواصل
الدفاع عن نفسها في مواجهه من يدعو
لابادتها بحسب تعبيره
رئيس وكاله الطاقه الذريه رافاييل الكرسي
قال في طهران ان هجوم اسرائيليا على منشات
نوويه ايرانيه هو غير قانوني
ادلى بتصريحات غير مناسبه خارج اي قانون
هل مسموح لايران التي تدعو بشكل علني
لابادتنا وتدعو لذبحنا هل نمنعه من الدفاع
عن انفسنا واضح انه يسمح لنا الدفاع عن
انفسنا ونحن نفعل ذلك من خلال المباحثات
والافعال على مدار الساعه ولا يمكنني
الخوض في التفاصيل اقول ذلك لانه لا شيء
في العالم سيثمن عن حمايه دولتنا ومنع
الظالمين من القضاء على دوله اليهود
اضاف ان اسرائيل تمكنت من عرقله تقدم
المشروع النووي الايراني لكنها لم توقفه
هكذا ان اسرائيل قلصت الفجوه لمنع ايران
من حيازه سلاح نووي
بعرقله تقدم مشروع ايران النووي لعقد من
الزمن عرقلنا لا تعني اننا اوقفنا اذ لا
يمكن ايقاف نظام حكم ارهابي يريد تطوير
سلاح نووي الا اذا كان لديك تهديد عسكري
حقيقي اذا كان هذا التهديد غير كافي
لتحقيق قوه الرضع فعليك تنفيذه انا اقود
هذا التوجه في اسرائيل وفي انهاء العالم
وايضا من قبل اصدقائنا في الولايات
المتحده تقديرات اننا خلصنا الفجوات بيننا
وبينهم لانهم يرون اصرارنا واسرار لمنع
ايران من حيازه اسلحه النوويه